I know they're my friends so Angelina
Jolie continues to get candid about her
kiddos all that mom stuff that just you
know means a lot this time in a new
interview with Harper's Bazaar where it
also feels like she threw a little shade
at X Brad Pitt when it comes to choosing
where she and the children live she says
quote I would love to live abroad and
will do so as soon as my children are 18
right now I'm having to base where their
father chooses to live yeah their father
aka Brad Pitt of course the oldest son
Maddox is living abroad for college in
South Korea have you stopped crying yet
did you have the ugly cry can't imagine
Angelina having yeah but did you have
the ugly cry Kim Barris your children
ugly cry the ax men times I turned and
waved I think I turned around six times
and he sweetly stayed and kept waving
knowing that I was going to keep turning
her and you could feel it he he knew he
couldn't important to remember Maddox is
also already 18 here's a little
breakdown for the rest of the kids pax
is 15 Sahara is 14 Shiloh is 13 and
they're twins Knox and Vivian are 11 and
Angie acknowledges they've all been
through a lot quote my children know my
true self
and they have helped me to find it again
and to embrace it they have been through
a lot
they wrangle me honestly et was recently
with Angie here's what she had to say
of course motherhood is my is the center
of when I wake up in the morning but I
think the truth is but what kind of a
world are we raising our children and if
we love our children we have to care
equally about the environment and if we
want to live in a fair and balanced
world that has equal rights and and
people are treated humanely we have to
care about respecting diversity
meanwhile ET has learned brad has also
been spending time with family his
parents down in Missouri
everything I've done on film I see my
dad I definitely see my dad
and I would say and then it's my mom my
mom is very giving that way so yeah it's
good she's got a big heart
et has also learned that last month Brad
and Angie asked the courts for more time
to settle their divorce
Angelina first filed for divorce in
September 2016 we will always be a
family and we will get through this time
and and hopefully be a stronger family
for it alright guys that is it for today
for all the latest on Angelina and Brad
make sure you stick with all things et
until next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye
for now
[Music]